Session Authentication, simply attempts to ensure that BGP
Routing messages sent between routers between AS's are
authentic. Now, this turns out to be a
little bit easier than it might appear, because
the session between these routers is a TCP
session. Therefore, all we have to do is
authenticate this session. The way that this is
done, in practice, is done using TCP's MD5
authentication option. In such a setup, every message
exchanged on the TCP connection not only contains the
message, but also a hash of the message with
a shared secret key. Now this key distribution is
manual. The operator in AS1 and the operator in
AS2, must agree on what key is, and typically
they do that out of band. For example, by
calling each other on the phone, but by calling
each other on the phone and manually
setting that key in the router configuration. But
once that key is set, all messages between
this pair of routers is authenticated. Another way
to guarantee session authentication, is to have
AS1 transmit packets with the of TTL of
255, and have the receiving AS drop any packet that has a TTL less than 254.
Because most [UNKNOWN] sessions are only a
single hop and attackers are typically remote.
It is not possible for the recipient AS to accept a packet from a
remote attacker, because likely that attacker's packets
will have a TTL value of less
than 254. This defense is aptly called
the TTL hack defense for BGP Session Authentication.